good morning believe nation today's
message is stack the odds in your favor
now over to you Theo Paphitis the main
thing I try and tell all my friends
family kids is do your homework why do
you want to compete with somebody on a
level playing field and be exactly the
same have the same chances of winning as
the next guy well you already know
you're a disadvantage so you need to
change the odds you need to tilt the
odds in your favor which means you need
an advantage because otherwise the next
guy is going to beat you now of course
if you got to casino and stack the cards
in your favor what happens they throw
you out beat you up even worse even
worse even worse in business or in life
it's called doing your homework and
being prepared and it's what you
expected to do stack the cards in your
favor there's no shame in that it's not
illegal is exactly what you need to do
in your life you do not want to compete
the same odds as everyone else so what
do you think I think there's a good
message there but it's very self-serving
you definitely want to stack the odds in
your favor but you can also collaborate
for example I'm a novice to youtube your
well established you've got a huge
following and yet Here I am standing
beside you I think Theo's message
definitely has all of the right
direction but he doesn't ever talk about
anyone else in the picture and I think
sometimes if you're in business or
you're in anywhere other department of
life your big picture can include
someone else and the odds that you stack
in your favor doesn't necessarily need
to be a manipulation it can be a
collaboration interesting I liked and
it's true here we are and and Matt came
up from Cleveland to do this session
me today when I think about stacking
odds in a favor the direction i take it
is I think you have to discover what
you're uniquely great at and I think too
many people try to do one thing but they
also have these other aspirations and
the real genius comes in combining them
if you want to be a lawyer that's your
big aspiration great this tons of
different lawyers out there or you want
to be a photographer you want to be a
writer like this there's tons of
different writers and photographers out
there why someone going to pick you is
because you're not just a photographer
you're the photographer who also loves
dance or who also loves sports or who
also loves something else and if you can
combine those things to be uniquely you
then that's when you start to see a lot
of traction matt is uniquely Matt I'm
uniquely me there's a lot of people who
copycat my channel and try to do what
I'm doing and it's a huge you know otter
and flattery I guess for me but nobody
can do me like I do mean you can't out
Evan Evan you know you want to aspire to
be the next Evon you want to aspire to
be the next Michael Jordan or the next
matter the next whoever you want to be
the first of you and you have to then
bring your own unique kind of art to it
by combining your multiple passions
together in my view that's how you stack
the odds in your favor and I like my to
take to about bringing a team together
so it's not just you trying to do
everything yourself I like your point
way better and I agree that when you're
trying to emulate someone you're trying
to redefine what it is you bring to the
table that's great and I think that
touches on the do your homework point
that could be research but that could
also be more self awareness so yeah I'm
fully on board for everything you just
said so the question that they today is
what is the oddest thing you had to
stack in your favor what was something
that caught you completely off guard
where you had to work that into your big
picture and you had never heard of such
a thing before interesting question
leave it in the comments below will join
the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso okay
this recipe me go